you're gonna have an IJ phone MacBook
and book detail this meetup
books-a-million out of his colleague
right now oh my goodness I'm standing on
phone sound or the sax that came from
book sign Amala sign you up what look at
all these iPhones hi Justine okay the
line weaves all those
see yourself leave a comment below I'm
blonde blogging for Justine's anyway
all right so here in Seattle ready to
meet you guys thank you guys so much for
having to always beside us it's been so
amazing seeing you oh my gosh all the
hoodies this is great
Steven J comes within the lots of my
friends came Jill what's up mr. zall sir
Massa it was great
real gamer wanna be gainer not real okay
selfish I'm like oh dude and I love
vitamin Mario Davis is true
congratulations on your book thank you
it's doors over holy moly